airline travel chaos in the United
States continues prompted primarily by
ongoing delays and cancellations at
Southwest Airlines one of America's
largest carriers that operates mostly in
the United States but also in the
Caribbean and Central America the
airline canceled over 2 000 flights on
Wednesday hundreds of thousands of
passengers left stranded and it's not
over yet the airline has preemptively
canceled more than 1 000 flights on
Thursday as it scrambles to reposition
planes and Crews during a system-wide
operational breakdown during a massive
snowstorm during Peak Travel season
the storm that triggered some of the
travel disruptions has mostly passed but
has left behind destruction and death in
Buffalo New York's second largest city
the city was subjected to more than 40
straight hours of blizzard-like
conditions it wasn't just Buffalo
further north in Canada homes along Lake
Erie were fully crystallized in ice
after the storm
but it was Buffalo that was hit the
hardest and on Wednesday residents were
trying to dig out and help rescue crews
look for anybody still trapped in their
homes or car behind walls of snow I was
out here trying to get my driveway clear
and they rode past and they see me out
here so they stopped and asked me did I
need help and I tell them yes and they
stopped and they did me and then they
saw him across the street and they
helping her and then I asked them nicely
could they do this lady over here
because she's in her 90s and that's what
they're doing right now the death toll
was expected to climb the Grim work of
recovering bodies left to the police
good news is a reprieve is in sight as
the temperatures are supposed to be
above freezing for the next few days
giving residents a chance to regroup but
it also means another worry of course
when temperatures rise all that snow and
ice melts turning into water so now
there's a real risk of severe flooding
the governor of New York is so concerned
about the flood risk late Wednesday she
announced she's deploying resources
there to try to deal with it more than
300 generators and 775
000 sandbags are on their way to Buffalo
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New York